hi there i'm conan o'brien
i know i've been gone for a little while
and some of you are probably wondering
hey conan where have you been what
you've been up to
well frankly it's none of your concern
mind your own business i'm sort of
trying to assemble some of the old team
get them together
and talk about
what's in the future so please welcome a
man who still is getting paid despite
the fact that my show ended
over a year ago
and still as far as i'm concerned we
have
no clue
as to what he does
george schlansky jordan come on in
how are you jordan good thank you
we have not seen each other since the
show ended a year ago
and i just wanted to know how you're
doing i'm doing fine thank you would you
care to elaborate um i am adequately
progressing through this period of my
life
okay
so you feel that
optimistic about the future i'm neutral
neutral yeah okay have you had covid no
i have not you never got covid no i know
how to protect myself from the various
threats that exist oh i think that virus
wanted nothing to do with you
that virus was laying waste to everyone
children old people completely not
discriminating and then old kovid came
along and was like
oh
i'm gonna be over here
we found the cure for covin
it's jordan schlansky
anyway glad you didn't get kovid okay i
had it because i'm an appealing
personality
i wanted to talk to you
because in the one year
since we ended the late night show on
tbs
everywhere i go
i'm
besieged by people who say
we miss you
and we really miss seeing you and jordan
okay and so i just want to be frank yeah
your appearance has changed
okay yeah and i'm saying this is a
friend
and an employer
you don't look like the jordan that is
in all of the remotes that we did
together okay your appearance has
changed okay now let me tell you why
this is important to me i look amazingly
similar to the man that graced
television screens starting in 1993.
i'm agile
i'm lean
i am very serious about my diet i eat
soy
soy beans
but i only eat the shell of the soybeans
are you aware that the consumption of
soy may interfere with your body's
estrogen levels and consequently
testosterone have you thought that might
compromise that was a problem that was a
problem i was a double d
cup
are you talking about your breasts yes i
had full womanly lactating breasts i
didn't even know that now you tell me
flat
it was fun my point is that i have kept
this look going now we talk to you okay
okay look look over here look at this
beard my issue isn't with the beard
itself it's the appearance of the beard
what's happening here you're all gray
and then i mean look at this this is
quite unusual it looks like a tarantula
is [ __ ] your mouth
okay
i want this jordan okay the fact that
you now look i'm gonna guess 75 okay
maybe 80. hey and thanks for your work
in the korean conflict right you really
served our country i would like you to
do what i've done look at me
i haven't changed look at this
look at this these are funny moves i can
do this i'm here
i'm over here right
i haven't lost anything
you've gained what are you talking about
bulk no i have not if you could separate
out your head
from the rest of your body and weigh
your head
you might find that that weighs more
than your head weighed say 10 years ago
you think my face got fat
there's been a a widening
i won't use the word fat but and who's
to say that it's a negative thing some
people may desire this men go to the gym
and work out to build that kind of
nobody nobody especially an irishman
goes to a gym to make his face fatter no
no one's ever done that do you think ted
kennedy used to say well i'm uh i'm off
to the spa i'm gonna get more yet my
face made even wider
you think he did that no
i'm here to answer your question as an
objective observer it's possible
although i'd have to do more research
your nose may have descended a bit in
the front it's possible that the front
of the nose may have descended a bit i'd
really have to do further research look
at some old photographs and compare to
make that determination confident oh man
but i'm only acting as an objective
observer you're freaking me out look
look
from here to here you're really the same
good okay so
here to hear same
yes here to here things are going to
[ __ ]
here to hear okay and then what about
here to here there's i feel that there's
been an alteration and again who's to
judge it may be superior it may you have
may have intentionally
done it what i'm saying is uh what are
you unintentionally done what i've been
doing crunches okay i i do
you have to exhale when you do the
crunches do you understand it it's
important to breathe otherwise you get
an uh distended uh abdominal area i
don't know if that's your issue it's
important i breathe it may not be
necessary for you to breathe i see some
personality um changes in your life that
are reflected in your physical state in
the past year the show has ended you
feel as if you're contributing
adequately to
to the comedic population by doing a
podcast once a week and suddenly you're
like i'm gonna enjoy myself i deserve it
i worked hard all these years let's let
myself go
and this may have been an intentional
desire of yours i mean why restrict
yourself to strips of turkey when you
can eat pork chops okay if that's what
you're interested in consuming i'm not
here to tell you that it's wrong you
think i'm around eating pork chops i'm
saying i'm i'm telling you when was the
last time you ate a pork chop on pork
chop tuesday and pork chop thursday
also on pork
chops chops i guarantee you eat pork
chops because when you were a child
there was one pork chop too few on the
table of you and your siblings and your
brother neal took he always so now now
he's cooking you don't have the pork
chops neil always took the pork chop
neal always took the pork chop and he's
got it now to review you think that i
could do a little better i don't
disagree and i will address it what i'm
saying is
you have let yourself go no i did not
let myself go i just went see when
people decay physically sometimes they
let themselves go voluntarily and
sometimes despite their best efforts
they just go so you tried this is with
trying i maintain my grooming regimen no
wait i have my
this beard is incredibly groomed i don't
have angular colitis i've clearly
cleared the areas away from my mouth to
avoid a fungal infection okay this was
your plan to be tarantula raped in the
mouth
constantly and perpetually wherever you
go listen i know that our purpose here
is not simply for you to ridicule me and
belittle me i know that's not in your
nature i can only assume this is gonna
end at a prestigious beverly hills salon
or with some medical aesthetic
professional who's here to improve my
experience i am sure i'm happy to comply
let's let's proceed jordan no first of
all that was the old conan who had a
deal with a big network and could afford
that kind of [ __ ] would you mind putting
this over your beard so it looks like
flesh color i just want to see what you
would look like if we got you
back to the old jordan bye bye tarantula
let's get you back to looking like the
old jordan now this is not sophisticated
but it does let the viewer see a glimpse
of the old clean shaven jordan with his
fleshy face
get the old color back
there we go
hey good news listen to this
soon with no lead
no time to button
okay
can you give me that attitude and look
right in there
you're on your way back buddy boy